monday marks the 49th birthday despite
decades of warnings from climate
scientists the world is still struggling
to cut co2 emissions the main driver of
climate change now a handful of
researchers and private companies are
trying to fill in some of the gaps with
what were once considered fringe ideas
this morning brook silva-braga has a few
of them Brooke good morning good morning
guys we talked a lot about the need to
cut emissions in with good reason but I
want to show you something from the
United Nations climate panel
illustrating what will happen with
temperatures even if we end co2
emissions completely by 2050 5 as you
can see temperatures rise and stay high
for decades to come and because of that
disturbing reality some climate ideas
that were dismissed just a few years ago
are now slowly gaining traction but it
is slow to find the best real-world
examples we ended up having to travel to
another continent up on the roof of an
industrial plant outside Zurich
Switzerland under the scaffolding and a
ladder
we found rows of circular vents the
first commercial scale facility bringing
back what we all put up in the sky the
books is capturing co2 directly from
that just here out in the air it's
grabbing the co2 from the air yes
collecting it exactly Louisa Charles
represents climb works one of a handful
of startups neutralizing carbon dioxide
by removing it and reusing it we built
here because we know
have some energy the source is waste
heat from a garbage incineration plant
just below inside we have a filter
material which is highly selective so it
captures only co2 to make it a business
they needed buyers for the carbon
dioxide and they found their first one
just a few hundred yards away a
greenhouse looking for fertilizer
there's a big cherry tomato taste it up
and down the road professor Marcus
Friedel has started using climb works
carbon to make fuel in this reactor we
have hydrogen and carbon dioxide going
in and out comes methane the methane
comes out of a gas pump at rapperswil
University of Applied Science and into a
small fleet of cars what would happen if
I put methane in my car it wouldn't go
well no you don't have to me think are
not yet can I can I get one yes it's
about 20 car models you can buy really
Friedel says the beauty of methane as
opposed to say an electric car is the
gas is easily stored in electrics
battery relying on solar power in the
Swiss winter would be hard to charge do
you feel this is part of the solution to
climate change yes I I'm very convinced
that this is part of the solution for
climate change for that climb works
we'll need more customers and they got a
big one on the day we visited last week
this truck was delivering captured co2
to coca-cola at a picturesque bottling
plant in the Alps their Swiss carbonated
water vassar in the world's first
bubbling with captured carbon so these
are some of the first bottles yeah these
aren't the first bottles and of course
it tastes the same it's a normal co2
it's just coming from the air patrickv
it Wyler coke sustainability manager in
Switzerland convinced the bosses it was
worth paying climb works $600 a ton for
co2 which they could get elsewhere for
almost nothing
yeah it's more expensive but to change
something and still supports up to
company yeah you have to invest a little
more but even all the co2 in all those
bottles is less than a drop in the
climate bucket the plant here uses 600
tons of co2 a year humanity emits 37
billion tons each climb works scrubber
removes about one ton a week I looked it
up and I think my flight over here was
like half a ton
so it would take three days of one of
these just to offset my flight to get
here that's a depressing number that's
why we need more of them
but before you dismiss carbon removal
and you wouldn't be alone
consider this these intergovernmental
climate projections are counting on some
of this working oh yeah National
Geographic journalist Andrew rev Caen
has been following the climate story for
decades my journey on climate started in
1985 he's watched as years of failure to
cut emissions forced governments into
mathematical contortions to prove it was
still possible to hit their co2 targets
and limit warming so this concept
emerged of negative emissions like
something that actually it's a take-back
thing it's the only way to make the math
work the only way this family of ideas
is known as geoengineering it could mean
carbon removal like climb works is doing
planting millions of trees which of
course consume co2 even dumping iron
into the ocean to jumpstart its natural
co2 absorption but remember this graph
that we showed you at the beginning even
if we bring co2 emissions to zero
temperatures could stay dangerously high
for decades and so Harvard professor
David Keith has another idea
deliberately reflecting away some
sunlight dim the Sun just a little bit
dim the Sun just a tiny little bit we
already know volcanic ash does something
similar but blocking out the Sun on
purpose take one last look at the Sun
spring view
it's the kind of thing the evil mr.
Burnes
would do on the Simpsons and yet
spraying aerosols into the stratosphere
and reflecting back some sunlight is
probably also the cheapest surest way to
lower the global average temperature
there is a catch you don't really care
about global average temperatures do you
care about whether there's a heatwave or
whether your crops have enough water so
we know we can lower temperatures but we
don't know if it'll be equally
distributed what it'll do to rainfall
all these kind of hard to model outcomes
exactly Keith who is also involved in
carbon removal through his company
carbon engineering has spent decades
studying what would happen if we dimmed
the Sun but has run into massive
resistance to even the smallest
real-world tests much of the opposition
comes from environmentalists people who
spent decades trying to fight for
emissions cuts are terrified that if we
let this topic get in the open that
people will use solar cheering as an
excuse to keep admitting they'll say
yeah we got the problem solved that's
completely wrong your perspective is we
need to do both we absolutely have to
walk and chew gum at the same time
that's the argument from Clym works too
which is trying to dramatically scale up
their capacity and bring down their
costs and they're working to not only
recycle co2 and soda and fuel which is
carbon neutral but at this site in
Iceland actually bury it making it
carbon negative if we're not examining
all of these avenues we'll always have
that sense I guarantee 10 or 20 years
from now of Wow why didn't we pay more
attention to that option Clym Works
admits that to scale up to a truly
meaningful size there will have to be a
price on co2 emissions basically a tax
of several hundred dollars a tonne that
will make certain things like air travel
significantly more expensive so many
wild cards here you got to confront it
from all angles it sounds like one thing
is not going to be the answer and the
point that everyone makes that we can't
emphasize enough this does not replace
eliminating emissions it's in a dish
yeah that graph said it all to me I'm
still wrapping my mind around the dim in
the Sun yeah